uh at the end of the event as well
i'll hand it over to umesh
okay so
uh yeah uh great welcome back everybody
so
um our next presentation is going to be
by uh dan stamperkun who is a
professor of physics here at berkeley
he's he's also the
director of the challenge institute for
quantum computing
and the director of the center for
quantum coherent science
so
so sudan is a is a leader in
quantum atomic physics and
he
he's pushing towards an effort to
explore
new hardware in emo-based quantum
computing
um
so uh i i guess um this goes under the
name of uh you know with this with this
emphasis on future proofing quantum
technologies so
i'll turn it over to them
okay good you guys can see and here
yes andreas sort of yes we can
all right great um
uh
great so first of all um
let me offer my thanks to um the science
institute
for um being a uh really terrific and uh
crucial partner for the challenge
institute for quantum computation
um
you you it's been a terrific partnership
that has really allowed us to have
um
a lot of connection and a lot of uh
positive influence on on quantum
computing
um
i want to thank also uh um
we're all we're all hearing from time to
time um umesh is our is our uh link to
the simon's institute who's
um the the co-director uh who who sort
of oversees our our connection with the
symes institute and um as you know he
put a lot of effort into putting
together this uh very meaningful
industry day and i'm very grateful
for all that effort
um and then let me thank all of you for
uh coming and participating uh it's
really great to see um so many familiar
uh faces and uh other people that i've
sort of been reading about uh in the in
the quantum news over the years
so uh let me introduce the uh the ciqc
the challenge institute for the for
quantum computation
and uh here's our mission statement if
you will
we're formed in order to address the
fundamental challenges to the
development of the quantum computer
so i'll tell you a little bit about our
center hopefully i won't take too much
of your time
okay so this all began uh uh back when
in the book of genesis when the national
quantum initiative uh dictated that the
national science foundation should
establish uh several quantum centers for
uh
for quantum information science research
and also for workforce development and
then uh that is then developed uh and uh
five of those centers now exist
so uh last year uh three of these
centers were founded uh ours which i'll
tell you about the q sense center which
is uh centered in uh in boulder
the h can center which is a centered in
the midwest in particular
university of illinois in
urbana-champaign and then uh recently in
the last couple of weeks
perhaps the last two we'll see how many
more there can be
quantum leap challenge institutes were
founded there's they don't really have
uh snazzy names yet but one of them is
uh centered at the university of
maryland focuses on quantum simulation
and the other one centered at the
university of chicago focuses on
quantum sensing for biological
applications whereas
the one in colorado is more in the time
and space division of sensing so you see
that among these quantum leap challenge
institutes ours is the one that is uh
dedicated specifically to uh to quantum
computing and so is maybe uh most
relevant for the gathering that we have
here uh today
so in founding the uh the ciqc we uh sat
together umesh was critical for these
discussions as were several other uh
colleagues and we asked ourselves you
know what's the special role that an
academic institute should now play in
this very new era of uh quantum
information science where there are
major industry efforts which many of you
represent there's major national lab
efforts which we'll hear about in a
couple of minutes
and other government efforts to try to
build a quantum computer with all these
um large entities working in this space
what's the right role for academic
institutes uh such as ours to play and
the focus has been on this concept of
future proofing which is really
a question of of time horizons you know
i think an academic institute ought to
look um you know far into the future you
know you pick your favorite time horizon
whether it's 10 or 20 or whatever number
of years and we should be uh considering
uh what what will be the obstacles that
uh stand in in the face of the future
developments that we hope to see
and then um
uh what what what obstacles uh will that
new development create um you know what
what will quantum computers uh wreak in
the world and and how can we overcome
those challenges as well
so uh thinking about that kind of time
horizon we thought was very
complementary to what is happening in in
industry industry will be
you know perhaps
more focused on on the nearer term on
specific technology uh choices and
particular approaches but uh but you
know can't also necessarily be as
concerned with with the far future also
that farther future is a place where
academia and industry can come together
and interact without you know too much
concern about competition and on
intellectual property and all you know
secrecy if we're we can together look at
the farther future and we all agree that
we should work together on addressing
problems that arise there
so the research effort is focused
focused on three specific challenges
which you'll recognize one is the
challenge of developing algorithms both
for the nisk but also the future era
that will make the effort to build
quantum computers worthwhile
the second is continuing this tradition
of trying to establish quantum advantage
over
classical uh information devices in a
wider range of problems of greater
relevance and also a wider range of
platforms and a third is tackling sort
of at a fundamental level what all of us
are facing which is that our quantum
computers when they get bigger they also
get worse so
we chose in particular to focus on
optics-based or atomic based
platforms for quantum computing because
we felt on one hand they come in a
variety of scales so it's good to under
understand the problem of scaling in
these systems and secondly it seemed
like an area where there wasn't as
intensive development at the national
lab and industry level so we could play
a complementary role
in terms of what we actually do maybe
it's described perhaps by who we
actually are and i think if you just
look at this
cast of characters you'll sort of
recognize uh what kind of research
activities were we're working on i mean
these are all people that are working
already at the top of their disciplines
and what we're hoping to do with the
ciqc is is pull them together and get
some sort of value added by working
together in teams and perhaps also
including many of you as partners in
addressing some of these fundamental
questions
and the ciqc is
is a network of several institutions so
there's eight universities in total that
participate it's largely uh centered
within uh california but we also have
some
members from outside of california that
that provide really essential expertise
and then our institute also has two very
essential partnerships one of them is
the one with the simon's institute which
brings us all together today so you all
are familiar with the important role of
the simon's institute as as now the the
hub for theoretical quantum computer
science and then also ipam which is the
institute for pure and applied
mathematics
at ucla which plays a similar role but
in the area of mathematical sciences
if you wanted to work with us on
specific areas of research here's a uh
one recent version of the working groups
that are
to varying degrees active and pursuing
collaborative research within our
institute
some are kind of in the area of quantum
algorithms some are kind of in the area
of quantum advantage tests and some are
kind of in the more hardware and scaling
quantum systems area but if you look at
the specifics of these topics you'll see
that they cross over between the
different pieces of this research
program as as research and quantum
information science naturally does
we also
are very active in
educating students and postdocs also
faculty and then with the idea of
developing the workforce that is
probably going to go out
and work in many of your efforts and
many of the other companies that will be
established to compete with you
and we have a pretty broad range of
education and workforce development
programs i'll highlight a few of them
one of them is the establishment of a
master's program which uh which michael
uh warned us against in the previous
session but we do indeed have such a
master's program coming together at ucla
another thing of interest is uh uh
summer schools or sorry winter schools
which then turn into video boot camps
that we we hope can be used to educate
all of us i mean all of us at this
at this gathering have expertise in a
part of quantum information science and
maybe there's other parts where we'd
like to learn more so even at the
faculty or senior scientist level these
kinds of video bootcamps can be useful
and then another one which i'll talk
about in a second is this uh
undergraduate research program which
pairs undergraduate researchers with uh
indep questions posed by industry
five minutes remaining thank you in
terms of interactions with industry i
mean this is kind of what an academic
academic center i think should be doing
uh one of them is you know we have
programs and ideas for preparing our
students to enter and eventually lead
the quantum industry so
our students and post-docs will be
gaining access to all sorts of uh sort
of professional uh training
opportunities and we hope also that
partners in industry can help mold these
and also participate in them as some
sort of mentors
we also hope that the ciqc can establish
sort of a
zone where academia and industry can get
together and interact and talk about
what are those
you know those coming challenges that we
can work on together
and then third of course we are building
up the quantum industry workforce and we
have some specific plans and you know i
can't talk about the real specifics but
um but we should have a robust program
for internships that would take place
over the summer for undergraduate
students we have a lot of undergrads
deeply interested in these and also
graduate students in both theory and
experiment and also our post-docs
so now with all the industrialists
sitting in the audience here's what i
want from you
one is uh i would love for you to
participate in this quantum research in
industrial projects for scientist
programs so here this is led out of ipam
at ucla it selects top-notch
undergraduates from around the country
to work with industry and academic
mentors on problems that are posed by
industry so we had a pilot project or
the first year project where
a question was posed by ibm dmitry
masloff acted as the
industry mentor and it was a tremendous
success uh four students worked with him
uh and uh produced a very impressive
report which is actually going to appear
in a publication hopefully soon so i
would love for you to contact us and
participate in this program and suggest
good questions to work on over the
summer with
undergraduates who would be living in
ucla during that time
a second is i there's a huge appetite
for uh summer internships to go work in
industry so
contact us let us know what would be
opportunities we'll do our job of
matching those ideas to the people that
we can provide from our center
a third is we'd love for you to join us
in sort of an industry consortium we're
forming two hubs that would either be
focused in the bay area or in
the los angeles area and this would let
you play uh what we need is an active
role uh in in uh
setting up the exchange between academia
and industry so we can be you know
working on things of mutual interest
and then finally you know please stay
informed there's a way of uh knowing
about the simon's colloquium that
happens weekly the ciqc colloquium that
happens weekly and other events and we
would welcome all of your participation
so that's it uh thanks for your time
great
thanks a lot dan that was a great
presentation
um
so
next on the on on the program we have a
presentation by
rick mueller
he's
the